foreign
Youngstown Ohio hi Emily how are you
uh good how are you good to talk to you
you too how can we help
income or go back to work full-time or
part-time or stay at home with the kids
uh we have been following your baby
steps for like four years
um we kind of have been working to this
point we have two little kids we
um uh we paid off all of our debt we
saved up for a 20 down payment on house
and I think we weren't as prepared for
me to cut my salary as we thought we
were and we're struggling kind of to to
make the budget every month now that
we've moved to one salary and
um
yeah just you know we've been having a
lot of conversations like should my
husband look for an increase in his line
of work should I look for something
part-time how much is your house payment
uh our document is 966 what's your
husband's take-home pay a month
uh a month is 2900.
so your house payment's one-third of
your take-home pay
and how many kids you got
two okay how old are they
uh three and eight months okay
and so he makes forty eight thousand a
year
well okay maybe I should have special
that so it's it's a variable pay so
there are like months that's that's
how much is annual income uh 67.
okay that's not 2 900.
so some months he gets
um more does that make sense like I get
like part of it is a very like it's a
variable case so part of it is the same
and part of it is a little bit of like a
commission sort of oh I see for some
months so the 2100 is the salary only
yes that's correct so that's not your
real income your real income is 67 000
minus taxes
correct yeah what does he do
um he is a sales force technician so he
works like it kind of stuff okay and
when did you all make the transition
from two incomes to one
uh four months ago I'm a teacher so at
the end of last or I was a teacher so at
the end of last school year was I sent
in my resignation okay so did y'all buy
the house before you left your job
you did okay
I'm kind of wondering so have you all
done the math on about how much more you
would need per month to comfortably
cover your bills
yeah I mean I think between the kids
would be about
500 is kind of what we were thinking
five to seven hundred to be really
comfortable I I think you're uh debt
free and you have a 900 house payment
with sixty seven thousand dollars
income I think you've had some other
lifestyle things that you need to take
out but this is a doable budget without
you working if you want it to be if you
want to work to pass some luxury items
or to eat out more often then you can
that's up to you but do you have to to
survive not with the numbers you gave me
you have no payments but a house payment
your payment house payment's 900 and you
make a 67 000 income I don't think
you're budgeting well I think your
budgets are loose and you've not written
them down in in detail and the two of
you pinky swear and spit Shake by God
we're sticking to what's on this paper I
don't think you're doing that
well and I do wonder if there's
something
I do wonder if there's also like a
middle ground where you mentioned you
know do you take a job out of the house
and I'm assuming maybe you're thinking
you know an official part-time job or an
official full-time job but with five to
seven hundred dollars is the gap and as
a former teacher you could make quite a
bit tutoring and really work around your
kids schedule and and just have a lot of
flexibility so it's like if you don't
want to buckle down on that budget quite
as tight or you want to eat out or you
want to get you know extra clothes or
something like that and that's just a
lifestyle choice you want to make let's
let's clarify emotionally though what
we're doing here okay you can live and
invest for retirement on 67 with a 900
house payment you can do it if you
tighten your budget and you watch what
you're doing and the two of you write it
down and the two of you stick to it you
can do that now if you want to do some
things above that and you're willing to
work for those things
that's fine but you're not allowed to
say oh I had to go pick up a part-time
job because we just couldn't make it on
my husband's income no that's not true
you can't say that because you can make
it on your husband's income if that's
what you want to do but if you want to
do some I I'm fine with you doing some
tutoring but but but we can't say it's
because we couldn't make it you can make
it true well it's even admitted that she
she's been a little loosey-goosey on the
budget no question I can do that budget
in my head it's there